it's been a few GPU launch cycles since
board partners really cared to invest
heavily in to AMD video card designs and
and these cards for as competitive as
some of the GPS have been haven't been
particularly exciting we've gotten a lot
of refreshes in the last few years but
that's changed with navi sapphires our
RX 5700 XC Nitro+ is on our bench for
review today as one of the most
physically imposing kitted out RX 5700
xt models we've yet seen with a reported
MSRP of theoretically $440 baseline
we're looking to see whether the price
hike is worthwhile over not only other
partner models but also over the RT
x-series cards that hover around the
$500 mark today we're reviewing the
sapphire Nitro+ in depth for noise
thermals overclocking power and more
before that this video is brought to you
by be quiet and it's straight power 11
series power supplies the straight power
11 PSU is shipped from 450 Watts up to a
thousand Watts accommodating most of the
gaming PC build requirements you'd
encounter and focuses on delivering a
higher quality power supply that doesn't
sacrifice on efficiency or stability
noise is also a heavy point for the
straight power 11 using a 135
millimeters silent wins 3 fan that can
spin as low as 200 rpm for quieter low
load operation learn more at the link in
the description below this is a sapphire
nitro plus it is a higher end card from
the 5700 xt line it's quite large and
we're gonna have separate teardown on
this one and it deserves a standalone
piece because it is a as stated very
kitted out it's got a lot of interesting
features and my cooler design on the
board so we're gonna do a separate video
talking about all that today we're
focusing heavily on the unmodified and
unopened thermals acoustics and power
targets because power targets are a big
deal and a big separator on these
partner cards this when I was a triple
bios which typically you only really
want a dual V BIOS dual v BIOS is as you
work more and more with video cards you
start to appreciate it because it gives
you this safety in that if you want to
try something if you get interested in
modern or store overclocking with BIOS
mods things like that you're gonna flash
it on there
and there's no real risk of damage
because as long as you don't flash all
three of them or all two of them in the
case of dual of you buyers you always
have a backup you can always fix it and
you can restore both be bios's this
one's got three which is exiting the
point of necessity and just getting into
being excessive but we'll test all three
of those just for their stock behaviors
it does give you some room to play if
you want to try a couple of different
mods on if you get into maybe
competitive benchmarking stuff like that
but it does also have a practical use
it's just that getting into this class
of cards obviously more expensive and as
you encroach upon territory of a twenty
somebody super or r-tx cards you start
deviating from the comparison that
really would it would matter for the
most part which is how does it do versus
other partner model fifty-seven rx tees
and drawing closer to the comparison of
but should you just buy something that's
a bit more expensive still and get more
performance so we'll talk briefly about
that today the big thing though is that
thermals and noise especially with these
larger coolers you'll be able to drive
down the noise level at a given
temperature and so that's something
that's important to look at so it's a
triple axial fan card it's got a triple
v bios and then it's supposed to be four
hundred forty dollars and it's got a
thirty dollar RGB fan add-on which we
don't have here but once you're doing
that you're really a you've basically
priced it out to a completely different
tier of card because you now have four
hundred seventy dollars so anyway let's
get through all the testing will look
pretty detailed at the thermals and do
some line graphs on frequency behavior
then we can talk about overclocking and
if it's actually worth it there almost
have been getting trickier to measure
even with 40 DB a noise normalized
thermal testing
varying maximum power budgets on each
card make the comparisons imperfect and
so a card which draws 220 watts will be
disproportionately hot when compared to
a card draw in two hundred watts even
with the same noise levels before
getting into thermal testing we need to
look at power consumption of each B BIOS
on the Sapphire Nitro+ there are three
of them we're using GPU only power draw
for this so this doesn't count memory
power consumption and vrm efficiency
losses
we're just looking at GPU here's a chart
showing the Sapphire
I'd show power limits for each of the
three V BIOS options ignored the hard
downward spikes these are reporting
errors and have no bearing on the actual
results for the default V bios position
the leftmost one power consumption runs
at about 220 watts constantly this is
higher than most of the 5700 XT cards
actually all of them that we've measured
so far and for the most part that's a
good thing that means more overclocking
Headroom in theory or more clocking
Headroom in general over or not the
middle V bios measured the lowest of the
three plotting at about 195 watts
average and closer to competition the
rightmost V bios also plotted at about
220 watts for reference if we look at an
average DV a power graph to best
understand the different cards on the
market the Sapphire Nitro+ is the most
power hungry of these models meaning
that it has more power allowance for
boosting the clocks without software or
powerful a table modifications the MSI
evoke only has 1 V bios and that V bios
runs at 200 watts average EMA size of
oak is roughly equivalent to one of the
V biases for sapphire also at nearly 200
watts and the Sapphire 5700 xt pulso cv
bios is also in this range the gigabyte
gaming OC runs a bit lower at 190 watts
average with the reference card the
lowest measuring 179 watts average GPU
only our next test will look at 40 DB a
noise normalize thermals but there are a
few explanations first as always testing
methodology is defined a bit more in the
article below
but the basics are that this testing
allows us to better look for efficiency
of cooler designs by eliminating the
ability for coolers to blast their way
to the top of the charts with it louder
or faster fans it's not exactly a fair
comparison if there's a 60 DB a cooler
doing better than a 40 DB a cooler
obviously and so we normalize them the
downside of this is that power really
should also be considered because the
Nitro has a V BIOS that pulls 220 watts
and another that pulls about 195 200
will measure both the 195 watt version
will be directly comparable to every
other partner model tested thus far well
the 220 watt version will pull more
power than the others thus running
warmer noise measurements will be taken
with a DB meter at 20 inches away in a
room with a noise floor of 26 DB
romanian temperature is measured second
a second and AC is controlled to 21
degrees Celsius with
offset modifiers applied if necessary
deviation and ambience is less than plus
or minus one degree Celsius and humidity
is controlled to approximately 45%
starting with noise normalized GP
thermals then we'll be looking at both
the edge and junction temperature where
the latter is a measurement to the
hottest spot on the die with the former
being a measurement of the literal edge
temperature of the dice one of the
cooler parts configured to roughly the
same power target as the competition
each power target is plotted on the left
axis the Sapphire Nitro+ is easily the
most efficient cooler on the chart
Sapphire manages an impressive seventy
two point five degree Junction
temperature winning the chart by a
longshot
it's not even close the next best is a
set of four cards all around the 81 to
83 degree range edge temperature is
nearly the same as the Gigabyte rx1r xt
that we tested but edge temperature is
less important than junction temperature
as junction is what dictates boosting
Headroom and a potential thermal limiter
for overclocking that's said with the TJ
Max of 110 degrees this is a non-issue
for all of the non-reference cards on
this chart Sapphire has a massive
incredible lead in this chart and if
you're wondering why that would even be
relevant if we're operating at levels
where lower thermals don't really grant
any advantages keep the following in
mind Sapphire could be run instead at
lower noise level still perhaps at 32 to
35 DBA in our bench while still
retaining equivalent thermals to other
coolers that might be louder like 40 DBA
this offers a noise advantage although
at the obvious cost of wealth more money
that's for the 220 watt Nitro+ version
it's managing the same thermals as the
pulse the modded evoke and the gigabyte
card but while pulling 10% more power
this is why if you just measured that
without accounting for the power
difference it really wouldn't look like
that impressive of a cooler the sheer
mass of the Nitro alone is helping here
not to mention the increased cooling
capabilities provided by the triple
axial design GTD our six and vrm Moss
testing is next for GGG our six thermals
the Nitro Plus at 200 watts
again comes out ahead of everything else
in fact the Nitro is so far ahead that
it's 220 watt V by experience is the
next best one on the chart
despite the 10% increase in power
consumption to the core at 200 watts
noise normalize thermals place the nitro
at 68 degrees G DDR 6 temperature with
the 220 watt option at 70
degrees followed by gigabytes previous
chart leading 70 4.7 degree results at
the end of the day as we stated in the
gigabyte review the actual difference is
sort of irrelevant once you get down to
the top three quarters of this chart
everything below the pulse and thermals
is and below meaning up on this chart is
distant enough from exceeding
comfortable thermals that they'd all do
fine there's no real benefit from
running mosfet or GD r6 a couple degrees
or even 115 degrees cooler when all the
results are already so far from the
maximum permissible values and you're
probably cooling based on GPU anyway
these don't behave like GPUs there's no
additional butene Headroom if a mosfet
is cold or if a memory module is cold
although there is potential for damage
if it runs too hot but in this instance
too hot means 125 degrees Celsius and
above on MOSFETs or about 105 110
degrees on the GD are six modules and
caps of course we're rated a bit lower
but they don't really get that hot on
video cards keep in mind that sticking
any of these cards in a case will raise
the effective T ambient from 21 degrees
to maybe the mid 30s in our environment
or worse if you're in a warmer ambient
and that's assuming a well cooled case
and maybe a light CPU load if you're the
type of person who prefers to run the
card stock and without controlling fan
speeds we've got some testing with the
cards left to auto to govern their fan
speeds for out-of-the-box thermals so
have fires thermals look a lot worse
than the 40 DB a result one left to auto
control but that all comes down to how
the fan curve is written the end result
is that the Nitro+ ends up mid-pack with
the right v bios which about eighty
eight point six degrees Junction with
the last V bios predictably next door
and the lower 200 watt v bios ends up at
about 91 degrees Junction but with
quieter fan speeds this chart certainly
tells a different story from the other
and if a reviewer tested only with all
the settings it make the nitro look a
lot worse than reality dictates
we'd suggest setting a custom fan curve
for the card if you're going to buy one
although these temperatures are
acceptable they're too warm for a cooler
this good and it comes down to how the
fans are programmed in v bios well plot
fan behavior now with the leftmost V
bios the fan ramps to about 1230 rpm or
roughly 37 to 38 DBA initial ramp is
much harder hitting about 1500 rpm but
it calms down
they're after the middle of eubiose
which sticks closer to 1000 rpm and acts
as a more silent option matched it's 195
watt power draw at 1000 rpm this card
produced about thirty-six point five to
thirty six point seven DBA of noise at
twenty inches in our bench the RPM is
fairly fixed otherwise with no
meaningful fluctuations to speak of as
for the full acoustic scale the range is
36.4 DBA to fifty nine point seven DBA
with our measurement we're in the final
ten percent fan of pwm doesn't really
move the RPM at all or much but this is
an AMD driver issue that's consistent on
all cards it's not a sapphire then two
of the 3v by OSA stick closer to the
1200 rpm mark with one closer to one
thousand rpm running at 40 DBA puts you
at around 1400 RPM for a point of
reference to the previous charts there's
plenty of headroom to scale up for
heavier overclock and without using
crazy cooling so this card may be a good
candidate for power play tables
frequency responses last before talking
overclocking for frequency response we
saw the higher power target via bios
options hitting about 1960 megahertz
with the lower 195 watt power budget
configuration running at around 1900
megahertz again a point of reference the
msi evoke not shown here but we have the
data in our review holds between 1940
and 1960 megahertz so we'll need to look
at some overclocking to further
differentiate needs on to performance
and overclocking results briefly again
the focus is not on gaming performance
here because they're all pretty much the
same this one's a bit different it's
special but most of the 57 hard XD is
one of the 2070 supers all those cards
within a given GPU skew most of them are
going to be basically identical to each
other
this wouldn't be different though so
this card had a particularly strong
memory with no issues achieving a 9 50
megahertz memory set and will need to
use power play tables later to see if we
can push things further this would
actually be a really good
liquid-nitrogen candidate and we'll see
if we can get the L&T pot mounted on it
because the frequent the memories are so
good we're not clear obviously on why
that is most the time it's just luck of
the draw it could be the IMC it could be
the memory cells probably the IMC and
whether or not sapphire does any real
bidding here we're not sure but it's
probably luck of the draw
core frequency seemed to succeed at a
set frequency between 21 20 and 21 40
megahertz which is really good that's
the max that AMD will allow basically
it's pretty damn close for the 5700 XT
you can do more with power plate tables
definitely and if you're into that sort
of enthusiast tweaking we absolutely
recommend it it might be something we'll
do separately if there's enough interest
in it and do a separate content piece on
we've done it before but this card might
be worth doing it again please note that
this is not the same though as get
frequency in this chart you're looking
at the labeling is set that's the number
we typed in the number that comes out is
always a bit different you can see that
in the time spot results some of the
overclock scaling down on the Nitro+ is
looking pretty good it's actually the
2070 super and the rx-7 hardac see
reference model are added here for
points of reference the 2070 super
managed a significantly stronger memory
score and gt2 than all of the 5700 X T's
and that's a significant portion of
where it's higher scoring is coming from
because gt2 weights pretty heavily so
this indicates that Navi is still stuck
on memory clocks
although the 5700 XC nitro did encroach
upon the total score of the 20 so d
super not shown here because blow out
the chart but the weighted scores are 10
won 8-1 points 10,000 won 81 for the
2070 super and 98 48 points to the
Nitro+ establishing a lead for the super
of about 3.3 percent won the super is
stock overclocking it would get you more
obviously
well the fifties or 100x the reference
under the quad nitrogen we scored 10 6 8
7 or 70 3.2 FPS gt1 and 58.8 FPS GG 2
lagging behind a gt2 really hard there
because the our reference model is stuck
about 900 915 megahertz memory Nitro+ is
the best on-air overclock we've yet used
for the 5700 XT although it remains to
be seen how much of that is from luck of
the draw again your mileage will vary
not may vary but it will vary that said
we're really happy with this particular
card and it's a fantastic candidate for
ln2 and for PowerCLI tables hopefully
that's true for all of them but we can't
say shout of the Tomb Raider at 4k the
5700 I've seen nitro with the stock V
bios ends up at forty nine point eight
FPS average ranking roughly tied with
the 27 super reference card are about 2
points
percent ahead of the Evoque and further
ahead of the 5200 icy poles over o'clock
in the Nitro+ but just past a 1080 TI
FTW 3 and equivalent to the Radeon 7
that distance from the r-tx 2080 gain
overclocking the 2070 super puts it past
the Nitro+ OC to be fair at 1440p the
Nitro+ runs about tied with RT x 2070
super and gtx 980ti holding a lead over
the RX 2200 xt pulse is 85 PS result
about 5.5 percent that's a much larger
game then we'll see elsewhere and is
absolutely a noteworthy one just don't
expect to repeat everywhere in GTA 5 at
4k there are 6700 xt Nitro+ stock V BIOS
Landers performance at 50 point 5 FPS
average ranking it as roughly equivalent
with the other 5200 XT cards on the
chart there's no meaningful gain at
stock overclocking the card manually to
a set frequency not the same as get
again of 21 40 megahertz and 9 50
megahertz memory the Nitro plus ends up
at 54 FPS average positioning at not
distant from the 2070 super the 2070
super reference card 7 FPS results
maintains a lead of approximately 5.9
percent over the overclocked 5700 XT
although the 2070 super could be further
overclocked to keep that distance
jumping to 61 0.6 FPS average here
granted a gain of about 14% over the
hybrid 5700 XT with an overclock the
Nitro+ manages the lead of 3.6% at 1440p
vr x 5700 xt Nitro+ performs at 102 FPS
average positioning that equivalent to
the Evoque and the charts with the lows
within the wider error of low
performance the Nitro plus ends up about
1% over the reference rx 2 D 1 or XT or
sapphire pulsar x57 r xt when either is
that it's 100 FPS average overclocking
boosts it notably to 107 a gain of 5
percent of the stock Nitro+ this also
ties it with an overclock to 2017
super-sorry non super non a die card
which was among the worst 2070 models
before being discontinued twice and
video discontinued the non a model which
this is that was the only a most RP
model at the time and then also
discontinued the 27 t the RT x 2080
maintains a lead of about 7% and strange
brigade with DX 12 and at 1440p the 5700
i've seen
Plus runs at about 128 FPS average
passing the 5700 XC pulls by 2.6 percent
and the pulse is a card that we were
pretty happy to recommend previously it
said well overclock is Nitro puts it
about tied with the stock 20 Sony super
and 20 80 while overclocking the super
allows it to leapfrog again
typically these partner board reviews
we're assuming that you already have
decided you want the GPU that comes on
the board that be the 5700 XT here and
that's because we leave most of the
gaming benchmarks and the baseline stuff
to the initial reference design review
where we look more at gaming performance
than anything else
so in these reviews we assume you
already want it and all we really care
about is comparison from one of that
model versus the next but here because
this is getting so expensive
not that 440 is particularly high but
it's encroaching on 2070 super territory
you can find them a lot of the partner
models are about $500 so should you buy
it is a tough question to answer when
considering RTX versus the other rx
models here's what we think if you are
looking at an Rx 57 or XT and you're
definitely gonna buy one of those you
just don't know which one this is by far
the best cooler that we've yet tested on
those models there's a lot more we
haven't tested but it's unlikely that
many will compete directly with the
performance all of this quarter you can
tell by looking at the design as as I
mean it's pretty obvious that it's gonna
be one of the best performers for
cooling it costs more but from strictly
a standpoint of 5700 T's the reason you
buy this aside from having some
additional power to play with an
overclocking although you can do that
through soft power play tables mind you
but if you watched our stream with Joe
that's a massive pain and they're not
particularly fun to work with so you get
a bit more power out of the e bios you
have some more flexibility on cooling
you can push the cooling harder and get
more clock Headroom potentially sort of
like competitive or a an enthusiast
overclocking standpoint we can recommend
the card it's good for that from a
cooling standpoint if you are really
neurotic about noise and you just you
can't stand
noise a benefit of these larger designs
is that you can drive the fan rpm down
quite low and still have better or
equivalent thermals to a lot of the the
less beefed up designs the smaller cards
especially so the point where you can
you basically can't hear the fans over
anything else in the system so that's a
benefit too and you do pay for that an
extra 10 20 bucks versus the other
models like the pulse or something but
those are the main benefits if you don't
care about either of those things
probably not worth it but if you're
interested in an enthusiast just kind of
hacking around with the card especially
with BIOS mods because you've got
backups here or you really enjoy the
idea of having a tunable fan curve to
the point where you still have good
thermals on the device but you can drive
down the noise to be below your system
ambient noise or system case fan noise
stuff like that it's good it's just
those are the primary reasons so we do
like the design the cards well done it
performs very well it is superior and
the charts for thermals especially noise
normalized the auto settings are a bit
they're a bit soft we think that
Sapphire probably should have gone more
aggressive with the fan curve on that
but that's nothing you can't solve by
just setting your own fan curve or
potentially flashing view bios if they
release updates
versus the 20 70 super that is more
difficult it's basically you'll you have
potential for more gaming performance
from a twenty seventy super if you're
willing to spend the extra money and
you're not that distant from it so then
it just becomes a question of would you
rather buy a lower and twenty seventy
super that is going to be a bit louder
on average and not have as good of a
cooler design comparatively but will
have more Headroom for a high-end gaming
performance or would you rather buy the
high-end 5700 XT get all the quality of
life features but then lose a bit of the
gaming performance and that's going to
come down to basically what monitor you
have what refresh rate are you trying to
hit what resolution is you trying to hit
and if this is priced at 440 it's not
unreasonable it's just at the high end
and we like seen high-end cards because
they're fun they're fun to work with and
there's definitely buyers for them so
good job sapphire on the design card as
well it's we don't really have any
complaints about it it's just it becomes
really difficult on the price and I have
a hard time picking aside between the
options but hopefully all that helps you
and if it doesn't and just look at all
the data and decide on your own make up
your own mind you have enough
information to do it thanks for watching
subscribe for more check back for the
tear down of the card we'll talk more
about the internals opinions on that
stuff and you can also go to
patreon.com/scishow and access or store
documents access data to help us out
directly like by buying one of our
shirts or our mod mats or toolkits and
I'll see you all next time
[Music]